[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich zeige euch heute wie ich bei
dem kräuter und gemüsegarten anlegen und
bei uns ist es bisher immer so gewesen
wir haben hier einen schrebergarten bei
uns in waghäusel der ist zu fuß etwa
zwei minuten von meinem elternhaus
entfernt und es war für uns in der
kindheit im omega praktisch denn wir
konnten auch alleine einfach zum garten
laufen uns hier austoben ernten pflanzen
gießen und zwar recht immer super schön
aber meine mama war so sehr der fünf
kinder und war dann auch eben irgendwann
vollzeit mama hat von zu hause aus
gearbeitet und hat eben nebenher mit
meinem papa zusammen der voll
berufstätig war eben auch diesen garten
gepflegt und früher waren es auch
wirklich total normal da haben hat man
sich selbst versorgt hat es ganze gemüse
und obst angebaut hatte alles in
unmittelbarer nähe
heute wo natürlich auch viele in der
stadt viele haben schon ein eigenes haus
möchten den garten direkt vor der
haustür weil sie einfach nach der arbeit
nach dem studium und neben den kindern
nicht auch noch zeit haben und garten in
der ferne zu pflegen
deswegen zeigt sich heute wie auch bei
euch zu hause auf dem balkon auf der
terrasse oder bei euch im garten einen
gemüse und kräutergarten anlegen könnt
so ein schrebergarten hat schon viele
vorteile man hat so einen viel platz die
natur ist einfach überwältigend schön
also ich habe es hier wirklich sehr sehr
genossen und man hat aber auch ganz ganz
viel platz
der nachteil ist natürlich man muss die
ganze zeit am boden arbeiten klar kann
man hier auch hochbeete anpflanzen aber
das haben wir jetzt bisher immer nicht
gemacht vor allem auf die große fläche
wäre mir zwar ein gewächshaus was nicht
gerade schön ist aber es war trotzdem
sehr praktisch wenn alles super gut drin
wächst gemüse häuser und gewächshäuser
gibt es natürlich auch schöne für den
eigenen garten zu hause
das kann ich euch auch mal in einem
anderen video zeigen aber ich will euch
heute zeigen wie wir zuhause den gemüse-
und kräutergarten anlegen und vor allem
als vorteil für meine eltern ich meine
eltern sind beide schon an die 70
beziehungsweise über 70 wir werden auch
nicht jünger
das heißt ich zeige euch heute wie wir
alles in einem hochbeet anpflanzen was
eben auch zu hause im garten auf der
terrasse oder dem balkon anlegen könnt
jetzt sind wir hier bei uns im garten
unser garten ist wirklich so richtig
schön geworden also eine kleine
wohlfühloase wo wir auch spielen können
also die kinder die können hier toben
spielen
wir können die füße in den teig strecken
aber wir haben natürlich auch den plan
einen nutzgarten zu machen
und wenn man es bei der gartenplanung
überlegt okay der nutzgarten kommt hier
nach
in die ecke denn wenn wir auf der
terrasse sitzen und in den garten
schauen möchten wir den garten schön
sehen und so nutzgarten sieht er nicht
das ganze jahr über schön aus den
nutzgarten da ist schön so von april mai
über den sommer hin ist er richtig schön
dann wird ja alles abgeerntet und dann
hat man im prinzip nur noch erde die
übrig ist daher ist es immer ganz gute
nutzgarten dort anzulegen wo man mich
unbedingt im sichtfeld haben trotzdem im
sichtfeld also haben wir uns überlegt es
muss ein teil geben der richtig schön
ist und auch ein teil der vielleicht die
ganze schöne so eine tomatenpflanze die
noch nicht ganz gewachsen ist ist es
nicht das schönste was man im garten hat
von daher wird dann weiter hinten
gepflanzt wir haben uns überlegt den
garten jetzt so anzulegen dass für
hochbeete machen
murat alex und genäht die haben nämlich
gemeinsam hochbeete gemacht und gebaut
dass eine hoch bild video hatte er
bereits gesehen und genau so haben sie
noch weitere fünf hochbeete gebaut damit
ich die jetzt bepflanzen kann gefüllt
sind sie schon und ich habe gemeinsam
mit christian mit anna überlegt was wir
denn da alles rein setzen können sondern
hoch bietet viele vorteile natürlich
könnt ihr euer gemüse auch im boden
einpflanzen aber wenn ihr zum beispiel
nur einen balkon habt oder eine terrasse
könnt ihr so ein hochbeet auch wirklich
überall aufstellen auch bei euch auf dem
balkon oder eben auch im garten
man hat natürlich den vorteil die
arbeitshöhe ist wirklich ideal da muss
ich nicht mehr bücken schädlinge kommen
nicht mehr nach oben wie zum beispiel
schnecken oder auch wühlmäuse
ich habe auch den vorteil dass ich nicht
mehr düngen muss weil ich einfach diese
verschiedenen erdschichten habe die
immer wieder zu kompost werden und sich
selbst an von leidet dünnen also sieben
jahre lang braucht ihr wirklich keinem
zusätzlichen dünger die erde darin ist
ein nährstoff faltig und dem hochbeet
ist die erde auch immer etwas wärmer als
im boden dadurch wachsen das gemüse und
die kräuter auch viel besser und ich
habe auch eine längere erntezeit beim
anbau eures gemüse oder kräutergartens
gibt es kein richtig oder falsch
ihr dürft einfach das anbauen was euch
am besten schmeckt bringt nämlich nichts
wenn die tomatenpflanzen aber eigentlich
gar keine tomaten mögt also schau dir
einfach mal was esse ich was mache ich
was möchte ich in zukunft öfter essen
und dann gibt's einfach dinge die gut
miteinander wachsen und dinge die man
vielleicht vermeiden sollte ich habe mir
überlegt dass ich einfach schon fertige
pflanzen kaufen denn ich habe nur
begrenzt platz und möchte natürlich auch
dass alles schnell wächst und gut wächst
dass die ernte gut ist günstiger ist es
natürlich wenn man sagen
gekauft und dann die samen zu hause im
innern also im haus noch zieht so macht
es meine mama immer die hat man immer
das ganze wohnzimmer voll stehen mit
kübeln und zieht an ihre tomaten und
ihre paprika pflanzen
es hat aber auch den nachteil ich muss
viel zeit arbeit und kraft aufwenden und
es kann natürlich passieren dass nicht
alle pflanzen richtig schön gezüchtet
werden können
bei meiner mama funktioniert da klappt
ich bin da muss ich sagen nicht so ganz
erfahren deswegen steige ich lieber auf
die fertigen pflanzen und da ist ganz
wichtig kauf teure pflanzen nicht im
baumarkt oder irgendwo wo sie einfach
günstig sind schaut wirklich dass er in
eine baumschule geht oder zu einem
gärtner geht der weiß nämlich wir die
pflanzen zieht und vor allem nimmt
einfach auch heimische pflanzen die das
klima von uns hier schon gewohnt sind
und dann wird auch wirklich was mit dem
nachbarn nichts sagen und dann wird auch
wirklich was mit euren pflanzen wir
haben die pflanzen beim christian geholt
in der baumschule gemeinsam mit anna und
christian habe ich mir überlegt wie
kopieren jetzt einfach die hochbeete und
machen verschiedene themen daraus drei
hochbeete stehen nämlich in der direkten
sonne und zwei stehen am zaun dh sie
haben auch so ein bisschen windschutz
überhängen die auch richtig lecker
duften und die auch hübsch aussehen wenn
ich hier von der terrasse ausgang in
richtung garten schauen da kommen aber
auch gemüsesorten reihen wie zum
beispiel paprika chilis oder auberginen
alles das was praktisch vom hochbett aus
direkt auf den grill wandern kann
[Musik]
wenn wir auch genügend kräuter die wir
im sommer benutzen können uns den winter
trocknen können
[Musik]
ja sehr schön sache endlich ist der
morata perfekt für ein bewässerungs
schloss noch mal schauen wo ich gedacht
habe du hast keine ersparnisse verlieren
wir immer weiße handschuhe
pikant sportlich vergisst und nein das
war das wichtigste
danke sage ich morgen beim kochen wieder
saubere finger
[Musik]
also wir legen jetzt hier noch die latte
in hard rocks bewässerung mit ins bett
damit einfach die pflanzen gleichmäßig
und kontinuierlich verbessert werden
weil das ist ja ganz ganz wichtig auch
für den alltag
weil dieser trotz verbesserung reicht es
in der regel wenn die auf 30 bis 40
zentimeter abstand gelegt wird und damit
die schläuche nicht verrutschen und man
hier die entsprechenden halterungen die
passen wir auf den kann man nur so drauf
gibson und infiziert es dann ja wie
viele man darf auch dass sich relativ
schnell raus in der regel reiche es bei
60 bis 80 cm abstand so wie hier wo er
nach oben da machen so einer kurve genau
also man muss einfach dran denken und
die bewässerung ins hochbeet legen dann
muss man später nicht mehr gießen ist
doch toll oder einmal eingepflanzt und
dann muss man nur noch okay ein bisschen
pflegen
[Musik]
um ein pflanzen dann einfach hier
tennis macht born ausgraben dann
natürlich aus töpfen und hielt die
wurzel so ein bisschen öffnen einsetzen
ohne verschließen
[Musik]
dann geben wir gleich noch längeren
starb damit arbeiten in der länge
bisschen an giften und so haarklammern
oder auch professionelle klammern der
wein wächst damit die pflanzen klartext
wenn dann oben dran hängen und im winter
nicht umkippt
meine mama hat das immer gemacht bei
paprika und tomaten aus tomaten ganz
wichtig da weil die noch stärker
okay da gibt es sogar nicht mit spiralen
ist auf jeden fall weil es davon allein
rein akustisch gar nicht hin
überlege ich mir noch beim pflanzen muss
man nur beachten ist gibt gute und
schlechte nachbarn und am besten schafft
ja eine mischkultur das heißt in den
pflanzen die wenig nährstoffe brauchen
und pflanzen die viele nährstoffe
brauchen und verknüpft die dann in einem
hochbeet so dass einfach ein schöner
ausgleich da ist deswegen verbinde ich
auch gemüsesorten mit kräutern
denn es gibt gemüsesorten sind stark
zehre andere sind mittel cera und
kräuter sind zum beispiel schwach sei
also die brauchen am wenigsten
nährstoffe wenn man das so verknüpft
haben auch noch den vorteil dass gewisse
kräuter nämlich auch schädlinge fern
halten durch die ätherischen öle
dazu zählen zum beispiel rosmarin
thymian oder auch die münze
wenn wir jetzt auch vorne wieder diese
kräuter teilweise die kräuter
herunterhängen wie zum beispiel den
rosmarin zitronenthymian hat sich ja
auch ganz viele kräuter und viel gemüse
firma auberginen und zucchini kommt auch
noch ein hochbeet 2 haben wir auch noch
gemüse und kräuter also dies ist und wer
es gesagt hat uns bei sie fand ich echt
gut und die auberginen du sagst dieser
bis in die mitte pflanzen und ich es
jetzt besser drei stück tanzen wenn man
dann mehr hat davon oder eher eine weg
damit zimmerplatz von dauer also besser
wäre zu sagen
am anfang erst ein kleiner komisch aus
aber tatsächlich wird bald zu setzen
dass rhede ein finger wirklich viel luft
auch hat um den raum das erreicht werden
kann ist auch hier in pflanzen brauchen
ein bisschen platt bisschen zeit und
hilfe trägt tatsächlich mehr wirklich
ganz okay also eher weniger pflanzen hat
man mehr davon
ok fortsetzung hat ja auch ein und gehen
ans nächste rufen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tom kommt wasser ok jetzt mal an gießen
aber danach müssen wir nicht mehr
bewässern denn wer mit dem
wasserschlauch gelegt und das am besten
die man nicht wenn es zu heiß ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so weitergeht
[Applaus]
und jetzt hier einfach so metall am
stecker diese beschriftung stecker
nämlich sitzt und da habe ich jetzt mit
wasserfesten stift einfach drauf gemalt
oder draufgeschrieben die kinder wissen
dann auch an die scharfen chilis dürfen
bin ich dran und vor allem verwirft sie
normalerweise nehme ich immer ein kleid
der stift für drinnen und nur bei den
gewürzen die ich praktisch immer fest
nach fülle also besser was ich eben
wieder nach schule nehme ich den festen
stifter immer bleibt und bei die dänen
die wechseln so wildkräuter zum beispiel
unternehmens im kreis stiftung wirkliche
aber die könnte man zur not mit
nagellackentferner auch wieder
wegwischen und neu beschriften aber
draußen muss natürlich wasserfest sein
sonst habe ich immer was zu tun so was
schon mal einstecken
[Applaus]
januar also ist das erste hochbeet hier
haben wir gepflanzt curry kraut wir
vorne rosenduft für mich an weil er
einfach schön aussieht gut duftet und
ihr vorne einfach ein schönes bild gibt
das curry kraut es wird hier richtig
schön hoch so dass man eben auch hinten
dran das abgeerntete gemüse nicht sieht
also auch wenn bei der paprika später
irgendwann nichts mehr hängt der
karrierist wirklich schön hoch und dann
für später eben da auch die sicht ich
habe ich auch noch gewürze die ich sehr
oft benutzte wie zb web bohnenkraut oder
auch pizza oregano dem zweiten hochbeet
habe ich auch ganz viele gewürze wie
salbei der rosmarin der flache der hier
auch später herunter wächst ich habe ich
aber auch noch majoran oregano hiervon
noch oliven kraut wenn ihr möchtet kann
ich da gerne auch mal videos dazu machen
wie man welches kraut am besten
verwendet und wozu es am besten passt
aber ich finde das ist einfach ganz
kreativ und offen sein
es ist immer schlimm wenn man sagt ihr
ruf nach ihnen geht nur für kartoffel
dem rosmarin fast täglich auch zu süßen
gerichten ganz gut ich haben wir zum
beispiel auch schnittlauch gepflanzt
oder auch auberginen den kohlrabi und
auch andere paprikasorten im dritten
hochbeet sind auch nochmal kräuter oder
auch erdbeeren zum beispiel also alles
was zum thema tee oder cocktails passt
das was man eben nach dem essen braucht
ich habe da mintzel waldmeister ist
geplant und auch ganz viele andere
gewürze die tollen getränke passenden
toll auf zu desserts oder eben auch
erdbeeren
die auch in einem getränk ganz gut zur
geltung kommen so jetzt haben wir hier
unser t und cocktails und was ist das
hier das ist das süßeste ja wenn da ein
kleines bisschen ab machst du probierst
es schmeckt echt zuckersüß und
handschuhen vielleicht nicht ganz gehört
damit kann man auch die süße nach mit
den blättern
also da verbindet man jetzt das laub und
die frischen blätter sind noch bis auf
den körper beim klever mitgegessen
richtig süß das habe ich noch nie
gedanken gemacht wie wir geworden wird
klar
jetzt weiß ich so grau
[Musik]
sie haben jetzt minze aber beim in 30
die hat bei uns im hochbeet total
gebucht hat das ist auch so wenn wir da
nicht aufpasst über die alle das haben
wir hier eine spezielle google das heißt
für dieses geschenk an das gut verwenden
und da muss man tatsächlich mit
ausläufern extrem aufpassen dass als
trick würde ich empfehlen das machen wir
jetzt hier auch die in einem topf zu
versenken in hochbeeten okay sie ein
pflanzen mit dem topf dann lässig
kompakten aber dann haut ihn nicht ab
und bleibt in ihrem reich und es reicht
ja auch vergrößern
ok hab mal voll
[Musik]
eine gartenhelfer halle kannst du mama
oder papa aber vorsichtig
ganze endlich zeit gar nichts bringe
[Musik]
cocktails getränke und tee ich glaube
das ist mein lieblings hochbeet denn
hier hat man wirklich alles was man für
den tag braucht ihr in staaten mit einem
fruchtigen getränk wie zum beispiel ein
liter wasser mit zitronensaft und dazu
ein bisschen minze oder dazu ein beginn
ananas salbei
da könnte wirklich alles verwerten ich
habe hier apfel minze oder auch die hugo
minze ich habe aber auch eine zucker
mehl ohne richtig schön groß wird oder
aber auch die kleine terz band hier
vorne
ich hab den 40 salbei oder auch das
kraut der unsterblichkeit im vierten
hochbeet haben wir dann das thema salate
also flugs salate kräuter die wirklich
gut zum salat passen da kann ich mittags
einfach kurz auf die terrasse gehen oder
in den garten kann mir abgucken was ich
für den salat möchte uns wächst einfach
immer wieder alles macht
[Musik]
das reduziert das salat beta also kommen
hier noch verschiedene pflücksalat
reihen noch ein paar kräuter wie
schnittlauch und petersilie basilikum
alles was so richtig schön zum salat für
gehört
[Musik]
sauerampfer vor allem hat das meine mama
früher im garten oder jetzt auch noch
jemand als kind bin ich seine hin hab
den abgezockt und im garten hat mir
immer so ein tässchen voll salz und da
habe ich da immer den sauerampfer mit
bisschen salz gegessen so lecker
[Musik]
wir haben im kräuter und gemüsegarten
kräuter die sind nur einjährig so wie
zum beispiel basilikum der wurde nämlich
solange herunter gezüchtet so dass er
wirklich nur noch eine saison überlebt
und da ist es auch besser wenn man den
einfach im nächsten jahr noch mal neu
rein selbst damit einfach schön wächst
und der geschmack voll entfaltet wird
aber es gibt auch kräuter diesem winter
hart wie zum beispiel rosmarin und es
gibt auch welche die kommen dann einfach
jedes jahr wieder beim gemüse ist es
anders gemüse müsst ihr jedes jahr neu
setzen und ich sehe das gar nicht als
macht teilt sondern eher als vorteil
denn ich habe jetzt dieses jahr zum
ersten mal im garten direkt bei mir zu
hause und ich werde jetzt erst mal sehen
was essen wir was mögen wir was mögen
wir nicht und im nächsten jahr kann ich
einfach rotieren und sagen okay
vielleicht zwei tomaten weniger dafür
drei gurken mehr oder ich kann sagen
dass eine crowd platz weg und dem andere
kräuter mit dazu also da könnt ihr
einfach selber schauen und einfach mal
herum experimentieren was für ein oder
zweijährige oder viel mehrjährige
pflanzen ihr gerne mögt also jungs ihr
wisst ja im leben kann man ja viel von
der natur lernen von der tiere lernt man
viele tiere sind oft viel besser
zueinander die menschen aber genauso bei
pflanze und ich habe gelernt dass
schnittlauch nicht neben petersilie
wächst jetzt machen wir's mal symbolisch
genäht und schnittlauch naja du bist die
petersilie weil das haben auch die sich
auch warum petersilie weil im türkischen
benutzen auf die petersilie und
schnittlauch ich für mich erst etwas
deutsches ja und das problem ist dass
beide neben einander nicht mitwachsen
können weil einer von beiden decke
pitter naja das ist aber kein reiner
kommt raus kann es sein dass die
petersilie schnittlauch vernichtet oder
anderer strom je nachdem wer am besten
behandlungs gut dass mein team im salat
funktioniert ja weiß da passte ja
wirklich super zusammenarbeit können wir
zusammen aufwachsen also gibt in der
mitte den streitschlichter dass esther
rucola warum rucola weil alex immer der
ruhepol
dollar
zum symbol als symbol einer freundschaft
dürft ihr jetzt die anstecker hier
reinstecken ok petersilie und
schnittlauch rätsel auf also alex du
fungiert er immer als streitschlichter
ihr fast alle drei perfekt in den salat
so muss ist das vorlesen ex-kanzlers
morath petersilie der handball liga
weiter rein weil immerhin zu planen muss
man das so sein
musik steht auf dem hocker wusste ich
überhaupt den gleichen weg wie er sein
kann zum anderen geht's ja ich hatte
gerade alle zudem salate unkraut es habe
dazu noch sagen dass peter sehr kleiner
wächst und schnittlauch wechseln die
höhe wird da wirklich dass an der stelle
wurde nicht nur eine grüne verwies auf
dem salat können jetzt hier die korken
schön an den ecken hoch wachsen
ich habe auch andere kräuter wie zum
beispiel die verschiedenen basilikum
sorten da vorne borretsch weil es
einfach gut zu den kunden passt hat auch
so einen leichtfertigen geschmack den
haben wir hier noch mit dabei und eben
alles was man eben auch schnell absetzen
kann
um den leckeren salat zubereiten
und dann haben wir noch das fünfte
hochbeet das ist das was in der ecke ist
was man auch am wenigsten sieht dort
kommen dann die tomatenpflanzen rein da
kommt auch noch mal auberginen zucchini
kürbis und all das was wächst aber
vielleicht nicht ganz so hübsch aussieht
aber eben auch viel platz braucht hier
setzen wir jetzt tomaten rein da haben
jetzt vier verschiedene sorten und die
setzen wird auch schön und rein also
vermischt damit hier mal große kleine
gelbe und rote tomaten sind und die
brauchen relativ viel platz die sind
jetzt zwar noch klein und süß werden
aber dann richtig groß daher sind jetzt
auch die wunden hier hinten im hochbeet
und da kommen gleich nicht die stäbe
dran damit sie an den stäben entlang
klettern können
[Musik]
wenn ihr jetzt hier gleich eine gummi
schnulzen fixieren komisch nur deswegen
also kein festes seil damit das später
nicht in die pflanze einschneidet also
die gummi sport ist einfach sehr
flexibel wächst dann auch mit passt sich
der pflanze an und verletzt sie klappt
dann eben auch nicht und am besten macht
ja auch eine pflanzen wanderung das
heißt wenn ihr dieses jahr die tomaten
dort eingesetzt habt dann pflanzte sie
nächstes jahr einfach ein bisschen
woanders so dass die pflanzen immer mal
wieder rotieren und die nährstoffe eben
nicht immer an derselben stelle entzogen
werden das ist immer ein ganz guter tipp
gerade bei hochbeeten wo man eben auf
einem platz beschränkt ist meist nicht
fragt papa warum sich aus als für die
pool
es ging darum finden
das heißt kann man schwimmen teil strauß
machen mir dass ihr euch abkühlen könnte
im sommer vielleicht wird ja einer davon
ein frosch prinz ist ein froschkönig
schließt dann nur eine kröte küssel
jetzt habe ich das damals gemacht mit
papa und mutter im prinzip zwar immer
noch kräftig am rad ist immer noch eine
kröte
[Musik]
im fünften und größten hochbeet haben
wir die gemüsesorten die nicht ganz so
schön aussehen also ich jetzt sieht man
auch schon die stücke stehen da da
wachsen jetzt die tomaten hoch ich habe
hier vorne kürbis den hokkaido zucchini
sorten ein bisschen paprika und
auberginen hier dann noch ein bisschen
sellerie karotten mangold und noch
weitere chilis
[Musik]
wer mir jetzt sommer das heißt unser
gemüse unsere kräuter werden jetzt
richtig schön wachsen und wir haben auch
bestimmt was davon wir werden euch dann
immer in den stories mitnehmen noch
zeigen was ich daraus mache natürlich
auch in den videos aber irgendwann kommt
natürlich auch der herbst und der winter
dann wird alles abgeerntet und dann gibt
es einfach verschiedene möglichkeiten
wie ihr mit dem hochmut weitermachen
können entweder könnt ihr alles abernten
dann so eine mulchschicht draufmachen
und abdecken so dass einfach kein schnee
und kein niederschlag drauf kommt und
das um diese schönen nährstoffe
rauswirft
ihr könnt aber auch sagen ich pflanze
winter hat es gemüse zum beispiel wie
pastinaken oder andere sorten und könnte
die hier überwintern
und es gibt natürlich auch winterharte
kräuter sorten wie zum beispiel der
rosmarin da könnt ihr auch gerne sondern
folientunnel drüber machen und den eben
auch überwintern
aber dazu mache ich gerne noch mal ein
weiteres video wenn ihr möchtet also
wenn ihr sagt ich möchte wissen wie der
kräutergarten und wie das mit dem
gemüsegarten hier weitergeht mit dem
hochbeet dann schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
dann mache ich nämlich im herbst und
winter auch noch mal ein video wir
können ja dann so machen dass wir sagen
okay einen oder zwei hochbeete werden
jetzt winterfest gemacht und abgedeckt
die anderen werde ich dann mit
winterharten gemüsesorten bepflanzen
schreibt es mir einfach ob es euch
interessiert dann mache ich das gerne
für euch und jetzt soll ich euch noch
den murat der macht jedoch dass
abschluss wort und will euch einfach
alles im ganzen nochmal zeigen
ich fand wirklich ziemlich cool schreibt
mir gerne wir euch das video gefällt und
wir sehen uns wieder das nächste mal so
jetzt haben wir natürlich alles gesehen
war als gepflanzt haben und es ist
einfach genial aus ich habe gestern auch
die hatten da gehabt da christian herz
jedes mal angeschaut und gesagt jetzt
seinem leben noch nie so coole hochbeete
gesehen und das haben ja wirklich nur
mit abfallstoffen gemacht die wir mit
übrig gebliebenen baustoffen die wir vom
bau noch übrig hatten und gerade mit
dieser treffer fassade dann diese
holzfassade und jetzt haben wir das so
zum return den hochbeeten drin das ist
richtig genial den boden das hat man
auch so gewünscht ich wollte das alles
und wie sauber ist aber trotzdem
natürlich und haben uns für die
natürliche sibirische lärche entschieden
das ist langsam gewachsen sehr
witterungsbeständig und ich bin ja so
ein holzboden reinmacht ist einiges
günstiger als die bbc
der boden bei bbc die saison klar so ein
kunststoff holz gemisch und es war mal
nicht natürlich genug und wenn wir
einfach ein ganz normales öl wenn ihr
wollt dass die farbe sich so hält oder
zumindest lange so hält irgendwann wird
zumal vertrauen
aber wenn ihr jedes jahr zwei mal
vielleicht so wie es jetzt auch machen
würde hat sehr schnell gemacht dann hält
es auch ein paar jährchen und dem boden
wird immer geölt und und wenz
wandverkleidung ist da könnte es
lancieren und nicht auf dem boden bitte
lancieren weil ihr tretet ihr erst mal
drauf das bricht dann weg und sind auch
richtig cool aus auch diese
sockelleisten haben wir gemacht aus dem
holz dann haben wir noch überall so ein
lichter drin
das heißt es abends ist leuchtend
richtig schön diese beete nach oben und
es ist einfach genial schön und sauber
aus habe ich recht und natürlich wird es
im garten hier auch hier wird es nur
einiges verändern da hätte ich gern noch
so eine kreidetafel wo ein paar sachen
reinschreiben vielleicht verändern wir
noch im mit mit deko ein paar coole in
ein paar coole deko elemente machen wir
gleich noch rein und ist einfach genial
aus oder du hast vielleicht einmal die
höhere investition aber hast lange
freude daran und haben mit rob schlauch
und durch diesen topf wird automatisch
bewässert in der stunde kommt ungefähr
1,5 liter wasser und wenn wir das mal
eine stunde bewässert dann ist das schon
genug
hier kann auch die möhren zeigen diese
nämlich direkt schon auf seinem sarg
teppich trug das heißt dass nicht so
viele sagen aber auch nicht zu wenige
und sie wachsen direkt in der reihe akku
wie würde es daran gemacht
einfach hier einsetzen 2 cm erde drauf
und fertig jetzt erde drauf moment was
hier noch die reihe dann haben wir hier
[Musik]
die arbeit im garten wir wahrscheinlich
nie enden aber es macht spaß ja ruhig